On va rêver
On va quitter ces murs de prison
(c'est tout à toi maintenant, vas-y !)
On va s'aimer,
Sur une étoile ou sur un oreiller
(A bord d'un train ou dans un vieux grenier)
Je veux découvrir ton visage
Où l'amour est né
On va s'aimer dans un avion, sur le pont d'un bateau
On va s'aimer à s'en brûler la peau
A s'envoler toujours toujours plus haut
Où l'amour est beau
On va s'aimer, aux marches des églises
Se réchauffer au coeur des banquises
Se murmurer toutes ces bêtises
On va s'aimer, j'aime que tu dises
On va partir au bout d'une île
Redécouvrir la vie fragile
Se découvrir amoureux encore
(Encore, encore, à toi, à toi !)
On va s'aimer, sur une étoile ou sur un oreiller
A bord d'un train ou dans un vieux grenier
Je veux découvrir ton visage
Où l'amour est né
On va s'aimer dans un avion, sur le pont d'un bateau
On va s'aimer à se brûler la peau
A s'envoler toujours, toujours plus haut
Où l'amour est beau
On va s'aimer, sur une étoile ou sur un oreiller
Au fond d'un train ou dans un vieux grenier
Je veux découvrir ton visage
Où l'amour est né
On va s'aimer dans un avion, sur le pont d'un bateau
On va s'aimer à s'en brûler la peau
A s'envoler toujours, toujours plus haut
Où l'amour est haut
On va s'aimer
On va s'aimer dans un avion sur le pont d'un bateau
On va s'aimer à se brûler la peau
A s'envoler toujours, toujours plus haut
Où l'amour est beau